تناولنا في حلقتنا امس الجدل اللي صاير
حول المسلسل التاريخي رساله الامام اللي
بيتكلم عن اخر ست سنوات في حياه الامام
الشافعي رحمه الله لي كان قضاها في مصر
الجدل كان عن عده اخطاء تاريخيه مثل ما
سماها المنتقدين بدءا من استعانه الامام
بطبيب يعني مسيحي لعلاج زوجته وانتهاء
بحديث الشافعي باللهجه العاميه وكان من
ضمن الانتقادات تداول سور كمان لخالد
النبوي بنضاره قيل انها من العمل وقيل انه
وانها خطا لانه شكل النظاره مودرن وكمان
انه الشافعي ما كان بيلبس نظاره من اليوم
ظهرت حقيقه الصوره اللي اتضح فيها انها من
كواليس المسلسل واول من نشرها كانت حسابات
قناه الحياه العارضه للمسلسل واما الجدل
الاحدث كمان فهو اكبر من كده ففي شاعر
سوري اسمه حذيفه العرجي
بتغريده شارك فيها ابيات بياديها الفنان
خالد النبوي اللي بيق وم بدور الامام
الشافعي وقال انه الشعر هذا له هو مو
للشافعي والابيات هي هذه اللي جالسين
بتشوفوها امامكم الان وكانت ضمن مشهد من
مشاهد رساله الامام ونسبت له
اللي سمعتوها جايه للشاعر انه اصدقائه
بيرسلوها له انه هذه الابيات مول الشافعي
لا انها هي هذه الابيات وهو كتبها من عشر
سنوات وانه هو كان من زمان وضح الجدل حول
البيتين اللي الناس بتنسبهم للشافعي بس في
الحقيقه الابيات اللي هو وقال انه الامام
اكبر من كل قول ينسب اليه حتى لو كان شعره
هو شخصيا ووصف اللي صار في المسلسل بالجهل
الفظيع بالامام رحمه الله وبلغته الشعريه
بالتحديد وقال انه اذا يعني تفصيله مثل
هذه ما انتبهوا لها فتخيلوا حجم الكوارث
الاخرى الشاعر صعد اكثر من كذا وشكك في
انه اصلا في احد قرا او في احد من صناع
العمل قرا سيره الشافعي اصلا وعلى فكره
بالبحث في صفحه الشاعره الشخصيه على
فيسبوك موجوده الابيات ببوست ناشره من تسع
سنوات وكمان موقع الديوان المتخصص في
الشعر واللي بيضم اكثر من 11 الف قصيده
لاكثر من الف شاعر موثق الابيات باسم
الشاعر السوري كمان
كمان خلينا نضيف على التطورات اللي صايره
في الجدل اللي صاير حول رساله الامام
تنويه اتفاجئ فيه المشاهدين في اول الحلقه
السادسه ما كان موجود من قبل وبيقول
التنويه انه العمل رؤيه دراميه مستوحاه من
احداث تاريخيه وانه بعض حكايات العمل من
خيال المؤلف للضروره الدراميه ناس كثير
اعتبرت التنويه هذا اعتراف غير مباشر من
الصناع بالاخطاء ومحاوله للهروب وايجاد
مخرج من الجدل والانتقادات
[موسيقى]